there's a lot of smoke and mirrors in
this industry man i mean more than i
could explain in a podcast episode but
what's the chances of the board ape is
just one big scam these guys are just
gonna like hit the hit the freaking
highway the craziest thing is that
there's a lot of
you know rhymes with yahtzee imagery
behind these board apes
people don't talk about that much
there's a guy on twitter who i you know
people debating i did notice that
i did notice that so i had this guy i
had this uh guy brett on the brett
phillips baseball player on the podcast
last week and he taught me about the
board apes literally last week
and uh
so
me and a friend of mine went and bought
one and it has a we has this crazy
helmet on it here i'll show it to you
and it's we just looked it up today and
it's some [ __ ]
uh
it's like a german nazi helmet
i was going to say the only thing i
could think that rhymes with yahtzee is
nuts
but i don't know if i was missing a word
or if i'm like yeah so there's a lot of
historical references behind the board
api club and i'll send you guys this
afterwards i was very doubtful i thought
maybe it's a coincidence
there's a lot of stuff that just you
know and i'm not saying that they are
definitely
definitely intentionally doing this but
there just seems to be a lot of
coincidences here they're definitely too
big to fail there's the the board apes i
would be very surprised if they did not
last
probably you know for conceivably as
long as nfts are a thing
unless something drastic happened
because they've got they've hit critical
mass you can't go back from justin
bieber aping right they could get
cancelled
i doubt it for being for wearing german
world war ii helmets
but the powers that be behind crypto
don't want that to happen who are the
powers to be well there's twitter and
then there's crypto twitter
and crypto twitter has a
what would you say like a different set
of rules crypto twitter is an
interesting side of twitter it's very
different from anything else
but like you know this you know when i
say the powers that be
it's very general topic because it's
hard to trick down track down who those
are but cryptos run you know
there's a lot like i said a lot of smoke
and mirrors in this industry that i'm
trying to cut through
um and a lot of people have been made
enemies of other people because they try
and do the same thing you know
but it is what it is i think that
ultimately
we will see this space grow and evolve
to where people can recognize that you
know what i'm saying
uh like one of the things that i see a
lot so i also i have a side thing i'm
doing i partnered with dow maker which
is uh like the number one like legit
crypto launch pad in the space shout out
to the dow maker team i'll send him this
video
um and we're running something called
infinity pad so i've learned how to to
kind of do ido's initial uh you know
offerings and
not not available in america shout out
to my non-american friends
but uh there's a lot of vcs in the space
that are just out here to just get their
bag
there's a lot of you know vcs and lps
that are just down here to use defy and
web 3 to do the same thing they did in
web 2. and it's very frustrating to see
that so i think that we can build a
system that makes them
obsolete and that's kind of what i want
to focus on doing so that they don't
have control beyond the space because a
lot of these projects have that so are
base are all nfts reliant upon
bitcoin mining or ethereum mining
because ethereum the only way ethereum
transaction like those gas fees right
those gas fees are because you got to
pay for the people that have the miners
right you got to pay the miners to do
those transactions
so so ethereum is ethereum
reliant on mining
yeah for now for now until it goes proof
of stake or whatever people think
ethereum's the only network you can have
that t's on that's not true oh it's not
true no yeah no there's a ton of
different networks there's so much
there's solana there's environmentally
friendly avalanches
that don't have the impact that ethereum
has like my newest thing is is avax
avalanche nfts
i love that whole ecosystem it's so fast
so clean
um
and it's just got so many more use cases
than i think even even ethereum nfts do
really i'm yeah i'm here for it i'm
definitely making the transition over
to give you guys some history in this
space like 2017 was about the crypto
currencies right emphasis on the
currency no one cares about that right
now bitcoin is one okay no one's
replacing bitcoin used to be bitcoin
cash and bitcoin had a thing going no
bitcoin cash is gone
nowadays it's about the layer ones and
layer zeros
to give you an example that's
essentially networks like ethereum that
projects can be built on top of and it's
been a mad dash
for which which layer 1 layer 0 etc
whatever you want to call it which
blockchain platform is going to win the
race you know i made a bunch of money
shout out to this man here off of a
layer two called polygon matic that was
my biggest w last year yeah that's the
other one that you can buy [ __ ] with on
uh on open seas polygon yes
which is great i put a grand in at a
penny
i i i bailed out at 90 cents
and then it shot up to two dollars
that was funny
look i'm not mad about it it was still a
nine what 900 x return 9 000 next return
wow on one investment like it was yeah
that's insane yeah it was great so you
guys are just watching this [ __ ] all day
long all day
well for me
it
goes back to why why i couldn't be a
creator at the time
was
because
building a business is just insane
especially one that has the amount of
like
i think we're at 18 employees now
something like 18 employees and
and we have like three different
business models all under one house and
all thriving you know like
we're really trying to be a holistic
company in the space that's doing a lot
we want to do cool stuff we've worked
with some really cool brands we've
worked with really cool creators
and so we're just trying to
you know scale up here as far as we're
going i mean i'm pretty i'm pretty happy
with our team right now yeah treating
bots launching in two weeks we got the
media company we've done over
i think our best month was something
like three quarters of a million in
deals
and then uh and then we have our discord
community which we just we broke a
hundred thousand last month that took a
small dip i think we went down about six
seven thousand when the crypto market
took a nosedive but people don't want to
see their portfolios they don't want to
they don't want to think about it they
don't want to think about it seems like
the people that get the richest off that
stuff is are the people who just forget
about the crypto they have or they
forget about their wallets
that's the best way to be i'm completely
emotionless like even though you know
my portfolio goes up and down yeah i
think really what separates the people
who are gonna make it in
early technology
like crypto
is the conviction that they have behind
their investments it was not easy to get
here everyone's like oh my god you're so
lucky you invested in ethereum when it
was early you invested in bitcoin when
it was early
yeah okay we saw our portfolios i hit
six figures when i was 17.
i saw that portfolio decimated over the
next year and a half two years you don't
understand like people people think it's
easy it's not easy to hold an asset down
90 and then back up again that's not i
watch my account go from 68 000 to 3000
in 2018.
yeah you stayed on the train though
right oh yeah i didn't sell a thing
nice the only ones that get hurt are the
ones that jump off yeah i mean i i tell
people not to i tell people to take
their profits because you don't want to
be stuck holding the garbage networks a
lot of stuff from 2017 ain't here now
and it's going to be the same way next
time
it's just how it goes you know you got
to consolidate into what i call the blue
chips
ethereum is a great example of that yeah
ethereum's a blue chip
no it's not going anywhere it's the
bluest of blue in my opinion what do you
mean by that it means like ethereum is
not about to die tomorrow okay there's a
lot of vaporware
projects like stuff that is clearly
experimental and for whatever reason
could fail
you know even the biggest
biggest projects in the space in 2017
are shadows of their former selves you
just never know what's going to last so
ethereum and bitcoin are like the two
biggest ones right those aren't going
anywhere
yeah and look everything that i invested
in back in 2018
is still or 20 even 2017 26 is still
around today and then there's some new
ones that i've added on that just
they're they're blue chip quality you
know that the networks are too large
there's too many people using them yeah
and the real thing is just like find use
cases it's one of the hardest things for
like real new use cases to come about is
so many different projects come out and
they just want to they want to build a
coin
and
they come up with a problem to solve but
there's really no problem there it's
it's in it you know this gets compared
to like internet in the late 90s where
everybody had a website for everything
and it's like that's great you can have
it up but is it really worth anything
it's bringing value to people how many
people are actually going to know about
or see about it or if you have 50
websites doing the same thing which
one's going to come out on top
and
you know it's it's
it makes it really hard in this space
for the
the new projects that are true blue and
like really solving a problem
to be
found or heard of you know because you
just have thousands of there's ten
thousand [ __ ] projects twenty thousand
coins you know it's a trial by fire it's
the crypto market is throwing [ __ ] at
the wall and seeing what sticks for some
of it and the projects that get really
big will make those investors a lot of
money you know you're early investor and
polygon like we were great
but as soon as they said it speeds up
ethereum and i was like
oh
i've been on ethereum it's slow as [ __ ]
i was like yeah this is something
that'll pop off like if i can trade on
this or i could do something on this and
it makes my transactions faster
this is it was that one cent i was like
this will be a dollar easily
i